foreign
welcome to rational science the only
site on the internet that does physics
rationally
today we're going to do a little bit of
Extinction followed by physics and we're
going to have our physics critic
we're going to analyze one thing he said
about explanations versus descriptions
and finally we'll open up the floor for
some of the questions and comments that
people made since last time
so uh let's get on with the extinction
segment turns out that there was bad
news this week you know the uh Chinese
or the Germans one of those communist
countries uh they attacked the American
Empire
a premeditated attack and they use a
very sophisticated weapon
and it's got nothing to do with
conventional Weaponry or or even nukes
more powerful than that
and they uh called it you know to
deceptively right they called it a
balloon
and here let me show you uh what I'm
talking about okay
uh this is what they sent over okay
as you can see it's uh flying around
cities
spying on Military targets they even
chase some people and the United States
immediately the Air Force you know
Center planes to meet it
and uh you know they weren't gonna call
it with their pants down again like in 9
11. Biden gave the order to shoot it
down
and that's what they did they just shot
it down and this monster this flying
whale went down in flames
okay
so uh yeah very very uh significant uh
issue because here you know they they
sent this thing over to attack
without any provocation
so uh you know as a result of that you
know Biden issued uh a decree and from
now on all hot air balloons are
prohibited in the United States you're
not allowed to fly in a hot air balloon
because it's considered to be a spy
device
and the Air Force will immediately
approach you and make you comply with
the law okay so yeah I suggest that you
know you or should be worried about
flying uh you know over especially over
military installations and
um
and in China you know as a result of
that they first admitted that it was
their uh device right they said it got
lost and whatever but they were angry
that the United States shot it down and
you know pinched their balloon
okay and so because of that they uh took
a little Vengeance today and they were
developing a weapon okay over some years
now in secret
and today they uh they attacked the
United States one more time but this
time you know uh I got some footage
exclusive footage from my comrades over
there in China and this is what they
sent me okay and just want you to see
this okay this is what they're up to
okay they built this new weapon
and here it is
and with this weapon
they do more than pinch balloons okay
they're going to be using this for
something else they're going to be
bringing down satellites that you know
are spying over their country and they
said you know that if the United States
is going to pinch their balloons you
know
the satellites okay
so I guess uh we're now in a uh
balloon War
I guess
uh this is a new
turn of events in in the world okay so
yeah as soon as we get into these
balloon wars you know we're talking
about high tech here uh maybe uh the
world is coming to an end soon
anyways in other matters China also
complained that you know the United
States is trying to contain all the
chips going to China which United States
says uh two things first that it's being
used for military stuff and then it's
also bringing China up to speed on chips
with the most advanced Nations and uh
they don't like that they don't want
China catching up and so
um you know the Chinese specifically
were saying that uh the argument they
raised was that it it's going to protect
they want to protect the existing supply
chain relationships and you can see
everywhere they just mentioned Supply
chains okay so they want to that's what
they claim to be protecting
um and they said that all the um
measures the United States government is
is taking
to contain all the chips from going to
China have to do with that with
disturbing you know all these uh
relations out there okay and again now
the issue there is that chips make the
world go round
and the United States doesn't want China
getting them they might get them in the
future anyways but United States would
like to
you know give them some lead time
so they don't catch up as fast
okay uh one fellow said here sent me a
note the previous week and he said uh
the following he said uh that Hiroshima
and Nagasaki so you do that you do not
know what you're talking about science
says both uh cities should have been
uninhabitable over a thousand years here
at their population doubled in 20 years
now has nine times its 1945 population
etc etc and I was thinking that he was
saying that you know the um that the
bomb never happened and he wasn't
referring to that he clarified this time
around that this is what he was talking
about he said I did not say people did
not suffer radiation poisoning after
being bombed in Hiroshima or Nagasaki
obviously people suffer from the bomb
okay I said that the bombing of those
cities did not make them uh
uninhabitable for a thousand years like
the science told us
well the issue here is uh whether uh
science told you that I don't know what
scientists you're listening to
you know I mean you get a lot of people
out there saying things and they say
well you can't live in that City because
it's been bombed and I showed the other
day how the people were walking the next
day
in Hiroshima and Nagasaki because
um they didn't even know what had
happened they didn't know there was a
nuclear explosion they just heard a big
boom okay and the next day they said
okay I'm safe you know and they just
went to work or to whatever activities
they had that day so even the American
public was kept you know in in the dark
as to what the United States government
had done because anyone people you know
protesting what they had just done so uh
this was in a way a military secret kept
from the populations both in Japan and
in the United States you know nobody
knew at the time that uh the United
States had thrown a uh a weapon a
nuclear weapon
okay but another fella he does believe
that there are no such things as nuclear
weapons and here he is he says the bomb
footage you showed was top stop motion
obviously by the fact that the
surrounding clouds did not move or were
affected by the blast wave in this
radius okay so they look at all these
details and this ah look the clouds did
not move okay
also after the aftermath of uh Hiroshima
and Nagasaki were simply fire bombs
which is why concrete fire proof
buildings were still left standing which
should have been destroyed by the nuke
yeah some buildings as you can see there
on the bottom some were left uh you know
the bomb doesn't really wipe out
everything for whatever reason okay if
you took uh look at the aftermath of the
bombing of Tokyo fire bombing Air Raids
it is eerily the same as Hiroshima and
nagasakis okay you also have to remember
that creating an atomic bomb is
impossible they say it is made through
the splitting nuclear fission of an atom
but people forget that you cannot split
the atom the word Adam literally means
indivisible okay that's true the
mainstream narrative isn't always right
bombs exist nukes don't they are fear
control
well in a way
um uh he's right about something let me
show you this uh the quantum atum it can
be partition you know the hydrogen atom
because it's made out of two particles
okay so you can remove uh
you know the electron I guess you're
breaking the atom you're parting the
atom you're splitting the atom when you
do that and we do that all the time with
ionization you know under the Rope model
yes you cannot break uh the atom up okay
you cannot chop it into pieces because
it's made of gazillions of threads that
make up the proton and it's encapsulated
by the gazillions of threads that weave
the membrane that encapsulates the
proton so good luck with trying to break
that into pieces okay so that's one
issue but the other issue you should be
aware of is that in the case of even of
the uh Quantum atom uh you know uh
you're talking about uranium uranium you
got to think of uranium as 92
hydrogen atoms plus some extra neutrons
there it's got 235 238 depending on the
isotope okay but um yeah what they're
saying is you've you've got this bundle
of balls even under Quantum Quantum
model right you have all these bundles
of balls each one you can think of as a
hydrogen atom and neutrons Etc and when
that thing explodes you know all these
balls
uh yeah they they break apart and so
that is the chain reaction that they
talk about Okay so
yeah you can split the atom okay
depending on what Atom okay and it's got
to be one of the even under the Rope
model only the hydrogen atom is
unsplittable anything made you know the
higher atoms anything made up two
hydrogen atoms or more that can be split
up no doubt about it well so in that
sense we're in agreement with quantum
mechanics as far as that issue is
concerned okay Phil also says the
following says the reason why those
cities weren't habitable was because of
the living conditions due to the fire
bombing new houses and no food from the
destruction not radioactivity
um once the cities were able to work
their way up and rebuild again it was
ready for people to start moving back in
and again I can tell you is that um
uh they um
they did not leave the city because
people weren't aware it was a nuclear
explosion I don't even think the
Japanese government knew at the time
until they figured it out not the next
day at least uh that what had happened
was a nuclear explosion maybe some did I
don't know you know but other people
didn't know they thought it was just war
and there was a bombing and a lot of
people got killed and that's all they
knew and they just went to work or
whatever activities they had the next
day but more important than that this is
what you should look at okay and here's
a listing of the cities that the United
States bombed uh using conventional
bombing bombs okay and here it is you
can see uh six main cities there
Yokohama Tokyo Nagoya Osaka Kobe and
Kawasaki those were the six main cities
the biggest cities in Japan I think they
still are some of those at least and you
can see all the other cities that they
bombed and what percentage
of the area was destroyed and you will
not see Hiroshima or Nagasaki on the
list
and uh here's a
here's something that I want to show you
here it's uh
what the city looked like Hiroshima
looked like before they dropped the bomb
here it is
and after the bomb there people going to
work the next day
okay so um
notice uh Hiroshima Nagasaki you know
they were not
um Bound by Conventional Weapons at
least in any significant way so you
cannot compare them to Tokyo which was
uh bombed quite a bit about 50 percent
of it got destroyed or the area was
bombed with a conventional Weaponry when
you're talking about you know the
nuclear weapon that was just one shot
and it obliterated especially the center
of the city and they did choose uh this
city partly because it had some military
installations and partly because it had
not been bombed so much and because it
wasn't as populated some of the other
ones okay so there were some
considerations in that regard
okay but if you want to look at Damage
Done by radiation which you don't
believe exists you know like uh nuclear
weapons uh or I guess uranium or radon
or some of those uh radioactive elements
I don't know if you believe in any of
those either you know I mean I think it
was uh William Renton in Germany who 18
well it was 1895 who uh discovered this
radiation okay and uh these are some of
the people who worked with it originally
and they were the careers okay their
family and all of them died from cancer
related to their exposure for so many
years in their Labs uh to radiation okay
and here are the queries okay Pierre and
Marie Curie and her their daughter which
was Irene and her husband and all of
them except Pierre died from cancer
cancer related or radiation related you
could say
diseases uh Pierre would have died of
radiation disease if he wasn't stepped
over by a carriage so he died uh in an
accident but he probably was glowing in
the dark as well okay and then the other
one that you might want to consider
researching if you don't believe that
nuclear weapons are possible here's the
case of these two fellows Harry dagnan
and Lewis sloden and they were handling
the demon core okay over there in the
Los Alamos when they were building the
bomb and this was after they dropped the
bomb over Nagasaki officially right a
couple months later and they had a
little accident nuclear accident over
there and uh the Thunder left Harry he
died within a month and the other fellow
went a few months later had a similar
accident and
um he died like nine or ten days later
from radiation so yeah you don't want to
have a radiation touch you okay you
might not believe in radiation and
nuclear bombs and all that stuff I think
it's a hoax it's just uh what the powers
that be used to scare the hell out of
people uh I'd advise you to do a little
more research on that subject okay
and finally this fellow says also he
says no one can rationally and
physically demonstrate what radiation is
he doesn't believe anyone can explain
radiation
well what can I tell you uh this is
quantum mechanics version especially of
radiation coming out of a bomb how a
bomb works okay in general terms okay
and this is their version okay you have
this chain reaction
and
um not only does it spit out radiation
whatever radiation is which is what this
get fellow is asking it's also shooting
out neutrons okay and so you have uh
radiation from Neutron radiation you
could call it and light radiation some
kind of radiation involving you know
frequency and wavelengths and that sort
of thing okay uh what's the problem with
this well
here I have synthesized it you can see
these are the atoms that they use to
mimic to simulate radiation okay and
those uh
those things that are being thrown out
those criticus well those are some of
that radiation they just paint them as
Curtis you and you say what are those
you know what's coming out of them and
is the atom fabricating this every
second out of what out of nowhere
there's out of space empty space how is
the atom fabricating all these photons
and waves and wave packets you know from
where from the center of the atom like
it's an inexhaustible Supply in there of
beans of balls of grains of sand is that
what it is
and uh here you see the waves okay and
so um you know you can see how
uh just the normal any any group of
atoms this is what you would see if you
had God's eyes okay
and uh the the
um atoms there are still you have that
electron rolling around okay uh the
nucleus falling from one orbital to
another energy level to a another energy
level or rising and by doing so they
emit these uh waves and all these waves
they form that radiation that word
called radiation and so he says this
fellow says uh we don't know what
radiation is okay we cannot explain it
well uh yeah Quantum cannot explain it
because what you're staring at all those
waves those are vectors those are
mathematical vectors and a vector just
has magnitude and Direction and it's its
direction is perpendicular to the
direction of travel of the whole wave
so what you're staring at is just a
bunch of numbers
with direction if you can make sense of
that and part of the process also in the
case of
um
nuclear explosion is you know you you
shake this and you have much higher
frequency of those same waves and here I
try to imitate that here goes you can
see they go faster okay and uh what I
mean by that is the wavelengths are
shorter so you get into the gamma uh
region gamma rays as they call them okay
um
and yeah this is this is essentially
what uh a bomb does it just as far as
radiation is concerned there's also the
neutron radiation here you'll I'll try
to imitate that simulate that they shoot
out all these neutrons as well so you
have two kinds of radiation the you
could say the electromagnetic radiation
and the neutron radiation which are kind
of like little balls okay and that's
what's going through you at high speeds
at high frequency high velocity and
that's what essentially radiation is
in uh in the world of quantum the
problem with all that again is the
Quantum atoms they cannot make sense of
the quantum atom which is a little ball
in the center that has an electron
tinier ball 1800 times smaller or less
heavy or whatever going around it
in different uh locations around the
atom
and the theory is that that little bead
which is what the electron is allegedly
considered to be in quantum mechanics uh
Falls and Rises through these energy
levels we don't know why because it's
negative it doesn't fall all the way to
the nucleus which is positive proton
right
you would think that positive attracts
negative so if you have a hydrogen atom
you know without anything else out there
in the middle of space you don't
understand why the electron doesn't fall
directly into the nuclear especially
when it's coming down to a lower energy
level why does it continue all the way
to the nucleus which was the question
they tried to answer at the beginning of
the 20th century that's what set all
these people you know rolling they said
how come the electron doesn't fall to
the nucleus and they never answer that
question they never did
and the other question why doesn't fly
out uh spontaneously you know they never
answer that question either so we have
no idea where this electron bead Falls
and Rises Falls and Rises okay that's
the issue well under the Rope model
obviously we have a different
interpretation of what a nuclear weapon
is looks more or less like this and
again it shows you that um
it shows you that
um
the the
that we can explain radiation because
radiation is simply
along one rope right that can
interconnects any two atoms you have a
torsion and then that's constantly
torquing and uh the Rope is constantly
torquing and then if you take the
aggregate although all that that's what
we call radiation so we do have an
explanation for radiation so does
quantum mechanics they do have an
explanation we do know we can explain we
can describe I guess uh what radiation
is
the problem with the quantum version is
that you know again they're atom and
that's where we differ with from them
here's our atom okay
okay these are atoms and they're
expanding and Contracting and what
you're looking at is essentially
um the electron shell that's expanding
and Contracting and by doing so it
torques the Rope what happens during a
nuclear explosion well things get a lot
faster and here let me show you let me
put this up here
so now you can see what's happening it
goes much faster
okay or higher frequency as they call it
well the ropes are torquing at a higher
rate and the atoms are pumping at a
higher rate and because of that you know
the uh links in the ropes are shorter
and that's why you get into the gamma
range and x-ray drains and all these
other good stuff and uh we you know
according to the Rope model it also
shoots out you know all these neutrons
because you're talking about uh what
you're really referring to here is the
uranium atom that's being split apart so
we have no problem with that so we have
no contradiction with quantum mechanics
in that sense okay
so let's get it straight what we have is
an atom and an atom is a membrane
the electron shell that encapsulates the
proton star made out of every thread of
coming from every atom in the universe
okay and uh any two atoms are connected
by a rope
which is made of two threads
and what the atom does expand and
contract and by doing so it torques the
Rope the aggregate of all of that motion
is what we call radiation okay so we do
have an explanation Quantum has an
explanation we just don't accept the
quantum version because they cannot
illustrate a hydrogen atom the simplest
of atom we don't expect them to
illustrate a 92 proton uranium atom just
one hydrogen atom will do and he can't
do that what are they going to
illustrate a proton with a little bead
going around it which is what everybody
illustrates out there
and then the quantum mechanics tell them
at the end well by the way that's not
our atom so we spent two hours working
with this atom and then at the end of
the show they say well that's not around
by the way you know it's not our atoms
okay so um here let me um
tell this well especially you know what
what to expect
if uh if a bomb is thrown okay and here
you will see uh how people react comes
from a movie this is Hollywood right but
how people react when there is an explo
a nuclear explosion or when one is in
about to fall okay here goes
this is what people do
they go to the store that's what they do
and they all look for what food okay
food that's the issue
and they kill each other for food they
fight if necessary everybody just wants
to grab a piece of the pie when when a
disaster is coming your way okay
so let's make sure we understand that
nuclear war okay that's what it triggers
triggers people to behave like animals
like what we are in reality okay the
only thing keeping us decent is the law
and the police otherwise I'm not sure we
would have a decent world out there we
would be going back like two thousand
three thousand years which where it was
the law the strongest
and here let me show you something else
which I want to share with you okay and
this is
this is also taken out of Hollywood but
it gives you an idea what to expect if a
bomb is thrown
hopefully it never does get thrown but
uh
you know we don't know what the powers
that be will do okay there is the
possibility
whether there is the probability that's
a separate issue but the possibility is
definitely there you know you don't know
what these people might do okay but here
it is one minute I want one minute of
Silence from you okay so that you can
see all these images and hear the news
and the noise so that you can get an
idea of what to expect if a nuclear
weapon is uh thrown here it is listen
carefully
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
now yeah that was made in Hollywood we
know and like someone said those are
scary cartoons yeah uh they're scary
cartoons but keep in mind that uh that's
what you can expect in real life from
nuclear weapons if you don't believe in
nuclear weapons I can't help you any
further but uh you know better do some
research on what nuclear weapons can do
and when I keep saying that if one
country whoever
throws throws one nuclear weapon even a
dirty bomb or whatever that's it I think
everybody's gonna start pressing those
red buttons and it's gonna be uh a
button War okay and I don't know we
might recover in the sense that yeah
someone someone's gonna survive no doubt
about it but it's like uh I think it was
Khrushchev who said the living will Envy
the Dead
a whole bunch of people that is why I'm
a nationalist women children babies that
is what we're fighting for not
high-minded principles or economics or
utopian society I care about my
ethnicity for the same reason that you
care about your family genetic
similarity or feeling ingrained in by
Nature I will support any group that is
in our interests I will use realistic
means to achieve objectives this means
uh these means are primarily educating
yourself becoming upwardly mobile
developing a network of connections
having many children proliferating new
ideas
okay what can I say
um uh you know here's uh
a story
that uh you might want to consider and
it comes from the Twilight Zone okay and
it has to do with uh your neighbor
and it turns out this fellow was
building a a bunker in his basement
and they kind of laughed at him joked
about it a little bit you know and
suddenly you know there was a scare that
there was going to be a nuclear war that
the bombs were coming you know
and so
the you know he locks himself in the
basement he's the only got food for his
family
guess what his neighbors do
and Rod Sterling uh put a good uh idea
on that I did a cover on this uh you
know so here it goes let me show you
this
remain tuned for an important message
the president has just announced that
previously unidentified objects
have now been definitely a certain as
being satellites
there are no enemy missiles approaching
we are in no danger
the state of emergency has been
officially called off
okay that's how your neighbors are going
to react so don't worry about the
Chinese or the Indians or the Russians
worry about your next door neighbors
those are the ones who are going to be
coming knocking at your door and this is
what Sterling has to say as a
I guess the moral of the story listen to
this this is what he says again I can
get a cover on this
damages
one of them is finding out what we're
really like
when we're normal
the kind of people we are just
underneath the skin
I mean all of us
a lot of naked wild animals who put such
a price on staying alive that they'll
claw their neighbors to death just for
the privilege
okay that's when we find out we are
animals and we think like animals when
things get rough as long as government's
there uh
uh to keep us you know
decent
but once uh once uh you know there's no
food and there's no protection
someone will try to take the upper hand
and there will be no Posse no uh Texas
Rangers coming to save you or anything
like that you know the Marines no uh
once that happens you're on your own and
at that point you're gonna fear everyone
who comes near you you had better fear
even if yesterday he was your best
friend so all I can say is uh that's
where you gotta look at this okay
um
and this is what I suggest to this
fellow okay uh you have two kinds of
people maybe some are Hermits and I
think the minority even to even though
today they're probably more more people
becoming Hermits and less social animals
you know party animals
um Fight For Freedom fight for the flag
for apple pie fight for the nation race
objectives
having children today in this day and
age uh you know I don't know what this
thought has gotten through his mind
populate what's he trying to do you know
populate the desert or what
too abstract and all I'm suggesting that
you keep it real fight for yourself
fight for your loved ones okay
and um that's different than fighting
for what objectives he said I had
objectives a long time ago fortunately I
wised up got out of my object today I
have no objective except to die yeah
that's my only objective but you know
fighting for apple pie and the flag and
all that stuff and uh the suffering of
other people on the other side of the
planet
well you know again if you're not Jewish
or Palestinian don't don't get involved
in Israel if you're not Armenian or
Serbia Johnny don't get involved in that
war and if you're not Pakistani in uh
Indian or Indian and Chinese don't get
involved in those Wars either you got
nothing in common with those people you
just worry about what's around yourself
you know drink your beer have a good
time play golf whatever you do you know
enjoy life okay uh when it's over it's
gonna be over and you're gonna say well
what did I Live Well I lived worrying
about the other world side of the world
that's what you're worried about
in other news we have this nose uh
autism diagnosis rate tripled in less
than in less than two decades what does
that mean for schools well um you know
uh the problem I've got with what they
say is that they say well it's genes and
environmental circumstances uh they have
this idea that
um it's got to do with environment and
food you eat and stuff like that and
they give genes uh you know lip service
they say yeah genes also no autism as
far as I'm concerned that's all I can
tell you is that uh it's been around
uh for quite a while a few centuries for
sure but
um it's gotten it's because we've inter
inbred for over 200 000 years that's why
we have people with mental problems
today aside from the fact that we're
crowded in cities
and again uh you should look at John
Calhoun's experiment he was a
psychologist look it up a utopian
Universe Mouse universe and he produced
autism and homosexuality in the lab okay
and uh
he started out with clean straight
mice ended up with homosexuals and
autistic mice in fact his comment was
that they stopped being mice
and the question is will we stop being
humans you know like
[__]
and just in case that didn't do it for
us we have this note Humanity will reach
its peak within just decades Trent shows
they're talking about the population of
the world it's probably going to be no
more than 8.8 billion in the end after
it reaches a peak of 10 billion and some
it'll start dropping down to 8.8 billion
those are the projections and um
and they say that all these fertility
breeds it says today the U.N says
two-thirds of the global population
lives in a country or area where
lifetime fertility is below 2.1 births
per women per woman uh roughly the level
required for zero growth in the long run
so they say because of this uh by the
end of the century instead of going up
the populations going down this is what
the graph looks like okay and you can
see that most of the population will be
in Asia and Africa and South America
North America and Europe it will be a
small portion of the world population if
things continue as they are now
okay so not only are we coming autistic
and have other mental problems but on
top of that our population is going to
occur you know the um population pyramid
is overturning on us and if you think
that's a recipe for another 100 years
200 years a thousand years a million
years
well think again you know uh not only
will that affect our population per se
but it'll affect our economics
and so you got to put all these
ingredients in there to figure out that
no we probably will not reach in fact I
say we will not reach the end of the
century and I'm not saying me I
certainly won't but neither will anybody
else yeah I think uh our uh
species is due for extinction
okay so let's uh move on here we're
gonna talk about
um
what is it we're going to talk about a
line today
what we're going to do is we're going to
uh
uh Define what a line is because some
people had problems with that okay and
so let's make sure we uh we all are on
the same page today after today we know
what a line is so how did we start well
we started the other day and we talked
about not the other day we talked to
already three or four sessions now on
the universal movie okay and here it is
ah so on the other side give me a second
here
um
here he goes
okay we talked the other day about this
the universal movie and we said it's a
tool it's a tool we use what to identify
objects one to define static Concepts
and to differentiate them static from
Dynamic Concepts and among the static
Concepts we have Direction okay
direction is a static concept some
people believe direction is a dynamic
con something that's moving or something
okay okay so that's where we started
okay let's just go with this and then uh
I had to Define Direction and this is uh
the path I took in reasoning okay I said
well we need these are things that you
require to Define direction or
apparently this is what you do need okay
you need two objects which automatically
makes it a concept because the word
concept is defined as a word that
includes or embodies two objects okay so
that part's taken care of uh we need two
objects they need to be facing and one
object no matter how it's facing one
face always faces another object okay
two objects have a distance between them
it's got to be between two surfaces
um
aiming
it has to be straight and it has to be
made of a singles piece you cannot chop
Direction into pieces direction is made
of a single piece or what you can say is
continuous okay so what are the
conclusions uh well it's a static
concept it's qualitative okay meaning it
doesn't belong to math uh continues made
of a single piece straight distance with
an arrow that's what essentially what
direction is requires two objects facing
and uh you can't have Direction between
Concepts okay so you really cannot have
Direction between locations
okay
um so those are the definitions I came
up with uh the two ones that I favored
was the first and the second one uh in
darker red line between two objects and
straight edge and then uh on the bottom
two lesser ones uh Mutual facing of two
objects and line of sight okay that's
where I ended up the other day
and some people had questions so I'll go
with the first fellow who had an
interesting question he said how does
one look at a frame and note the
direction of the object's points having
trouble with picturing direction as
static
and he does have a point here we have
two points two things two balls
and just by looking at that would you
know what direction is
okay could you conceptualize uh
Direction with just those two points
okay uh if you put a line there you know
in which direction is it flowing Etc you
know there are some questions there so
we thought that was a good question uh
that he put up there okay he's got a a
valid concern here's another fella he
did a little better
and he said static concept but straight
that doesn't seem right
you're absolutely right uh and
unfortunately I hate them because it
means I got to buy him a beer when he
comes to Germany okay that doesn't seem
right he's right okay [__] straight only
apply to objects in scientific English
yes absolutely is the Rope model rope
lies between all atoms as they should
seemingly have something to do with
Direction and they are straight aimed at
other objects are continuous
your first definition there line between
two objects is just describing the Rope
right how about Direction the
orientation of the Rope between any two
objects okay which seems to mesh with
distance the length of the Rope between
any two objects
okay he said a mouthful there the first
thing we need to clarify is that under
the Rope model okay
we say that any two atoms are bound by a
rope okay so there's the model two atoms
my fists and bound by a rope that's the
model that's a basic model okay so we
usually talk about distance as being
between two atoms or any atoms or things
you know made out of atoms we never talk
about uh distance between energies or or
Fields okay because those do not have
shape
okay so we have two atoms and we say
okay this object made of this atom is um
different than the object made of this
atom and so we don't see the Rope what
we see is this right and we say okay
what we have is separation distance
and under that yeah we can say that the
Rope is equal to distance because the
separation between two atoms is the Rope
the length of the Rope between them
okay but that doesn't cover
the distance between two ropes and
that's another concept it's like saying
the distance between two energies okay
because that's what the Rope is
considered under Quantum it's considered
uh just a uh ghost called energy energy
which is which comes out of the atom and
they call that energy that light that
electromagnetic wave or field or
whatever they want to call it they call
all these they have all these concepts
for that because all they did is measure
and give them uh names you know they
gave them units and numbers okay so not
always is distance
equal to the Rope just want to clarify
that but then you know we have we still
have a problem because these people ask
uh good questions okay and that put odds
and myself to work overtime we spent
over an hour discussing this and I'm not
sure we figured it out I'm just gonna do
my best here today so please don't don't
embarrass me too much okay I'll do that
I'll do that myself please okay so here
it is okay
let's start slowly here we have distance
okay we have two objects in our
Universal movie and we have that
um that stick there that white stick and
we call that distance but actually we
put that stick in there uh by force it
shouldn't be there uh in other words you
should not confuse the stick which is an
object with a concept called distance
which is what this file was referring to
okay this is what it should look like
this is what you see okay we put this in
there with our minds or sometimes even
drawing on the board right but this is
what's out there okay so let's just make
sure that we understand that part that
we do not need to stick to conceptualize
distance we tend to
um replace distance the concept where
you reify it and put a stick in there
and call that the line we call that
distance okay so let's make sure we
understood that part first okay this is
a little tricky because this this is a
very hard word to Define no doubt about
it
okay and so here let me show you
something else here we have distance and
also Direction I want to show you that
they are not Dynamic Concepts either one
distance or Direction okay so we have
distance and what happens is the
mathematicians they do not use the
distance at the top the stick
is separate which represents separation
again reification what they do they have
distance traveled which is you see on
the bottom one there for the distance
okay and if they're going to do that
what we recommend is that they reify it
but then they should put a line made of
dots or dashes so that we know that
they're talking about locations or
movement the solid stick simply
illustrates that it's a single it
replaces just the distance the
separation okay and the same thing with
direction direction you would think uh
all we need is just to put an arrow at
the end of uh distance okay and
direction is not a dynamic concept so if
you're going to represent Direction with
a dynamic concept you should use a
dotted or dashed line and again we're
saying that's wrong okay it's not what
direction is direction is a static
concept therefore if you're going to
reify it if you're going to use an
object to represent a concept at least
use the stick okay the solid stick and
not the dashed lines
and conversely for um for those who
think it's Dynamic at least be honest
and put you know the dotted or dashed
line that's what we recommend for any
reification of lines okay either you
talk about many locations numbers
whatever you want to call them or you
talk about a single separation
okay and if we illustrate them
differently at least we under we don't
get lost in the concept that it's either
static or dynamic okay let's keep the
illustrations right
okay so um
um
here we have the question this fellow
set asked he said look we have two dots
there
please tell me which way that thing is
pointing or what direction do we have
there and so it's a valid question
okay so let's see if we can answer some
of these questions and again
all I'm going to do today is really
embarrass myself okay but we'll do our
best if we can here okay let's start
with our uh
Universal movie okay here we have the
universal movie okay and we're going to
build upon this first we're gonna put
two objects there okay we have two
objects or two locations you could say
okay remember the object is different
than the location location has to do
with the set of distances between those
two objects okay
okay so now we are going to
conceptualize distance okay so what we
do is we typically put a stick between
them but remember the real distance is
this one there okay where there's
nothing between them and what we do is
we put a stake just to represent the
fact that we have a separation we'd like
to put a solid stick so that we know
it's not traveling it's not a bunch of
locations what we have is simply
separation from one surface to the other
okay so far so good
okay so now what's the issue the issue
is that when you are looking at
Direction okay you could say like I said
the other day that uh directions
distance with an arrow at the end of it
okay so here we have you know uh the
same distance but now we're going to put
an arrow we're not going to ask what the
arrow means or anything like that we'll
just say look it's distance with an
arrow solid solid stick right we're
going to put a an engine Arrow at the
end of it okay and so we say that's how
we illustrate Direction but even this is
wrong there's something wrong here
and let's go with what's wrong with it
okay and that's where I was uh misled
the other day by myself yeah
okay here's the problem the first
problem
first problem is that you don't need a
second object
when you have a second object it answers
the question this fellow asked and that
is how do we know what direction
and we're not trying to find out what
direction which direction we're trying
to Define define the word Direction
so when you put a second object there
when you put two objects two balls or
whatever you're talking about a specific
Direction
okay and uh and we don't need that
because direction is indefinite it
extends forever okay in that sense okay
so so you don't need to put a second
object to conceptualize Direction in
fact remember all these things are from
the observer's point of view the
Observer is looking at a frame okay of
the universal movie and uh inventing
Concepts that he gets out of the picture
the picture only shows you what you see
there in the second frame just a bunch
of little dots okay and in this case you
see one red ball and you see the line
that we put in there right but all you
have in in real life out there in the
universe are just atoms that's all you
have okay it's we The Observer who
suddenly
because we have such a sophisticated
mind
um
you we put in their concept we we invent
Concepts we we see more than what is
there we have this subjectivity and we
say look we have here a ball and we have
Direction which is indefinite just a
line there that we put to reify
Direction but we don't need a second
ball we don't need a specific direction
we just want to define the word
Direction
and what we do we are going to replace
in fact the first object as well what
are we going to replace it with well the
Observer is going to put his eye where
the ball is okay that's that's Direction
there Direction means that when you look
at something whether it's distance or
existence or in anything or any static
concept inside the universal movie
Universal frame just one frame the frame
just shows you one thing what you come
up with in your mind is is something
you're inventing that you're it's
subjectivity okay and in this case what
you're seeing is that uh we have to put
the I where the first ball was
and what you have is line of Direction
line of sight okay line of sight that's
what my final conclusion is until now
until someone can come up with a better
definition of Direction okay so I'm
saying that direction is simply line of
sight and by line I don't mean the line
of geometry line of sight is simply a
synonym of direction is what you're
staring at so we're not saying that
there's a line that you're going to put
a line in there even though you could
say that it's line of sight parallel to
a uh stick you know you could say that
to show that it's straight but yeah then
you cannot use the word straightforward
the word direction you can say it's made
out of a single piece if you understand
the context the context is you cannot
chop Direction in half you can add chop
Direction into pieces because direction
is made of a single piece so to speak
okay it's a concept that is made out of
a single okay and we call it line of
Direction I think that's perhaps the
best definition and
leave it up to people out there to come
up with better definitions we broke our
heads we couldn't figure out any better
than that so uh that's all I can tell
you right now okay okay but let's raise
an issue and it has to do with this word
line okay which has to do with direction
as well okay because we typically think
you know it's it's a direction at least
we replace it with a line to reify it to
put an object that we can see so that we
can relate to the concept that it
represents right that's that's the
notion here okay so here's my definition
of line which I've showed in the past
line is equal to an object equal to a
figure okay because there you see a line
uh what is objectively in front of you
well you see uh elongated rectangle
that's what you see there it's got two
ends one end here one end there okay
that's what a line is okay now
um it's uh just another direct angle you
can see that it has
um
for uh edges okay I showed three of them
there okay one on the top the one with h
which is the height and the one W was
this the width and then at the other end
you have the fourth one okay so it's got
four edges that's what you see in front
of that's what's objectively being in
front of you we're not talking about any
subjectivity any thoughts that you have
going through your mind we're just
talking about what's there in front of
your eyes okay
and it's straight okay conceptually
straight it's continuous made out of a
single piece okay in other words it's
not chopped it's not segmented or made
out of points locations numbers or
anything like that it's made out of a
single piece okay
and it's finite
as you can see at finite it begins here
it ends there and top bottom same okay
it's got four edges okay the infinite
line of geometry is not a figure because
figure is that which has shape it's a
synonym of the word object and the
infinite line is simply also made out of
points and it extends indefinitely
meaning you're talking about motion
you're talking about incessant motion
not about a physical object called line
which is what we have in front of us
okay
and so they said well that's a line
segment but even the line segment is
made out of points meaning out of
numbers locations they're talking about
motion they're talking about a bunch of
apples in the best of cases not about a
stick
okay so again the line of geometry is
not a line not a geometric figure
okay so what does this file say well he
says the phone he says uh well I say a
two-dimensional line and he says line
line is one dimensional okay and if you
look up uh in a Wikipedia it says line a
straight one dimensional figure having
no thickness okay so I guess that's
where he got this he just copied and
pasted and a drawing of a line is 3D
representation of a line a line is a
concept
and ask them why you know this is what
he comes up with he says because it only
resides in the minds of humans as an
abstract idea
okay so he thinks that a line is a
concept because it's only in the mind
not out there okay and again we're we're
he's using subjectivity where I'm
referring to the objective figure that
he's got in front of us okay the
objective figure
is a stick that's what we have in front
of us and what he's talking about is
what he's got in his mind what he's uh
interpreting
okay not objective but subjective again
only 3D can be an object all other
dimensions are conceptual and a fellow
answers him says abstract ideas have no
dimensions
an idea is not an object and thus has no
shape And yeah that's a pretty good
answer okay uh for what this fellow
proposed or copy he just copied and
pasted okay so let's let's go through
these uh those keywords uh why is the
line a concept okay and he says because
uh it resides in the mind where did he
get this from well here it is says line
object with zero thickness and curvature
that stretches to Infinity line and
infinitely long object with no width
depth or curvature lines are
one-dimensional objects and that's from
the Wikipedia so this is probably what
he copied or where he got the idea okay
and why is it a concept well here it is
it says concept an abstract idea what is
an idea the result of thought and turns
out that you know idea is a synonym of
concept but aside from that says idea
mental representation
representational image of an object
okay so uh we've got a lot of um
contradictions you could say or problems
with these definitions because you know
if it's um if if it's just if if an idea
is just a representation of an image or
an image of an object uh what are we
saying there
well we're saying that that's what just
what an idea is if if I tell a story
that's not an idea if I have a theory
that's not an idea only images are ideas
and again if you look up the word idea
it's a synonym of concept so concept and
idea of synonyms you can't use the word
idea to define the word concept or vice
versa okay so he fails with Concept uh
here we have
the question whether uh you know a line
is um
a figure does it belong in geometry and
here it is figure form or shape as
determined by outlines or exterior
surfaces to be round square or cubicle
in figure and so a one-dimensional
whatever uh line is that a figure
I mean what's the shape because they're
talking about formal shape okay geometry
a combination of geometric elements
disposed in a particular form or shape
again uh is a line of shape does it have
form
and all the examples they give they
don't put the point or or the line
remember they they just put these
circles and the squares and the cubes
okay
and when you look a figure in the
Wikipedia says a shape drawing depiction
of geometric configuration what's a
configuration well there is a
configuration in the plane
okay and what is it a finite set of
points or a finite arrangement of lines
okay so
um
they use the word uh point to uh to talk
well they use the word point but they
have not defined the point but then they
say uh configuration it's just a bunch
of points and lines okay so again uh we
still don't know what a figure is okay
and here's the point that they just
mentioned
point A Primitive notion that models an
exact location in space and has no
length width or a thickness so what kind
of
um geometric figure is that what is the
shape of a point if it has no length
width or or height okay which they call
thickness and it says it's a primitive
notion what is that it's a concept that
is not defined in terms of previously
defined Concepts we learned a lot okay
in modern mathematics a point refers
more generally to an element of some set
called a space okay let's see what a
space is okay and we look up space it
says space is a set
what is a set a collection of things
it contains elements or members what is
an element it's a member of a set
and the set with an element with no
element is the empty set okay
so I hope you learned a lot today with
all this you know these are the
definition of mathematics
uh yeah you can go on and on looking up
all these words and they have no meaning
whatsoever and that's why they say well
we cannot Define what a point is we
cannot Define what a line is but they
say it's a straight one dimensional
shape because it's got to be shape or
form in order to qualify as a figure and
they say it's a figure
so you can see there is a contradiction
there and that's why they say we cannot
Define what a point or a line is okay
and
um just in case you see they're
one-dimensional okay what's a
one-dimensional space okay a
one-dimensional space sequence of n
numbers can specify a location in
n-dimensional space when n equal one the
set of all such locations is called a
one-dimensional space
an example of a one-dimensional space is
the number line
okay so you can see that these people
just run around in circles and you never
get to the bottom of it is a line of
one-dimensional space what does it mean
well it means it's a set of all such
locations
yeah so
yeah you don't learn anything from
mathematics uh definitions because
they're all irrational every single one
is irrational they have never set the
foundations of mathematics on a proper
footing why because they use all these
concept these qualitative words
and Mathematics has nothing to do with
quality it has to do with quantity so
they're defining words that they're
going to use eventually in geometry and
by extension in physics but all these
words uh have nothing to do or you know
not one of them has anything to do with
mathematics mathematics is about adding
subtracting multiplying dividing you
know Powers
Etc calculus it's got nothing to do with
qualitative stuff and these are all
qualitative words
so this is where the problem is and so
they never were able to define the
qualitative stuff because they say well
you know we're not English Majors we
don't do that kind of stuff that's
that's what you know people who work in
libraries and so on you know write books
uh that's not for us we we don't do that
kind of work all we do is calculations
and that's what they call science
okay so um here we have uh final issue
on this and that's uh you know the the
fact that again you know that's a
summary of
conclusion of what a lion is yes what
you have in front of you is a lie okay
not what this follows a set what this
fellow said he reads more into what he
sees he says that's a one-dimensional
line no it's not because as you can see
it's got two Dimensions width and height
so it's not a one-dimensional line but I
challenge him to objectively right
um
scribble uh
draw take a picture of whatever a
one-dimensional line and he won't be
able to do so
Okay so
as you can see
um this takes us to where first the the
fact that the direction
is a um
is it hard to Define concept we reify it
with uh lines
and the line is straight the line is
continuous but the line is redefined the
concept
Direction
and that's where the problem is we can
do that easier with distance distance
you can reify it and say well it's
distance but you're not supposed to
confuse the stick with a concept fine no
problem we take the stick out we say
that's separation what's that space
between the two objects but that's not
as easy to do with direction direction
it's like you need to put that stick in
there uh to illustrate it with an arrow
at the end so you know which direction
but that only gives you a specific
Direction it does not give you the
definition in general of the word
direction the word direction the best I
could come up with is line of sight and
for that you the Observer have to look
at the frame of the universal movie put
your eye
in one any location any object so you
replace the object with your eye that's
what you're going to do
subjectively because again we're talking
about a concept okay Concepts have to do
with the Observer we created all
Concepts so you put your eye
okay you go through the motions of
putting your eye at any location any
object you want and you stare out that's
called line of sight and that is what
direction is as far as we're concerned
maybe you have a better definition
okay
okay let's move on to our uh science
critic okay
let's see what he has to say today
and he talked about the fact that uh he
believes it's semantics to talk about
the difference between explanation and
description in his mind they are
synonyms and if you get too much into
the nitty-gritty he said well now you're
doing semantics and I don't want to talk
with you anymore and and they walk away
they don't realize we have to resolve
these uh issues okay we have to Define
these words we cannot leave the room the
room is locked there's eight billion
people in this conference room no one
can leave until we Define the word
explanation differentiated from
description a lot of people think that
the next place is just a bunch of a
series of descriptions
and uh no that's not the case and so
they should look more closely at these
two words and let's go with what this
fall had to say first okay and then
we'll move on to
um answer him okay here it goes give me
a second here
he goes
no questions and answers to be addressed
in this rebuttal include
is a description the same thing as an
explanation
and
is pointing out the differences between
description and explanation
a trivial exercise in semantics
one day I hope that Bill gate will
realize that explaining and describing
are two sides of the same coin and that
all he's doing is talking about
semantics here
okay okay so what's the problem with
what this file says well let's go first
with authority okay because these people
are heavy on Authority so let's bring
authority to bear and here we have Mr
Donald simonik and this is what he says
he's a professor emeritus at the
University
physics and he says science doesn't
explain science describes
okay now why do you say that well
because he's not a physicist he's really
a mathematician a mathematician
mathematics can only describe and
therefore what the mathematicians have
done is equate science with mathematics
and so they said mathematics just
describes all we do is measure calculate
and that's called science
physics which they equate to physical
and that's where we have the problem
because that's not the type of questions
people ask a physicist people want to
know how the universe works they want to
know why a pencil falls to the floor
they want to know how a magnet by by
what means by what mechanism a magnet
attracts another those are the questions
people want to answer those are the
questions people consider part of
physics and those are the questions
these people can't answer because they
give you a an irrational explanation
and when you question them and say well
hold it that's irrational say well we
don't understand it either and we don't
care because it's not part of our job
description we don't do those kinds of
work that kind of work
and so uh that's what they say and hey
that's why this file ends up saying look
we don't we don't explain we just
describe
because that's all that mathematics can
do so that's the first thing we have to
note the second thing is that apparently
uh Mr Simone can tell the difference
between a description and an explanation
because he's saying science doesn't
explain science describes he's telling
you in your face
so if you think that explanation is
description and vice versa think again
okay he's telling you it's not it's just
that you're not smart enough to know the
difference
okay so come up to speed get on that
steep learning curve and try to figure
out why description is not an
explanation or vice versa okay science
we do not describe in science we explain
and we hopefully do it rationally
okay so here's the definitions that we
propose for description and explanation
you can see that there is a difference
and we should chop these words very
tightly we should Define in very rigors
rigorously so that you do not escape on
any tangent and say well description is
the same thing as explanation here we
make it black and white so that you can
see why a description is not an
explanation and those are the definition
we're going to hold you to if you have a
different definition for description
especially hey bring it on okay we'd
like to tear it to Pieces there it goes
okay description to describe right a
listing of properties of a physical
object
that's what a description is we just
list the properties okay so we said
chairs got four legs Brown made out of
metal whatever
that's a description okay and if you
measure it and say it's 10 feet you're
also giving me a description you haven't
explained anything so far
okay in science we use adjectives to
describe objects we use adverbs to
qualify or characterize motion we would
rather use by the way
um
a different
notion for when we have motion when we
have when we're for example describing
something that happened
versus describing a chair or a tree or a
rock
we would like to use a different word a
narrative and to narrate okay when you
narrate you're describing but you're
describing uh something in motion it
could be a movie or whatever a motion of
a tiger or whatever then you're
describing we call that narrate or
narrative narrative or narration
explanation what is that well that's a
little different the causes okay
underlying a phenomenon as far as
physics is concerned a physical
interpretation a movie of a mechanism
that's what it is to explain to disclose
the manner in which a consummated event
occurred and now you can see why
mathematics so-called science right uh
does not explain according to the
mathematicians because they cannot
explain they cannot explain in a
rational manner it's not part of their
job description
okay
and here are some examples okay again
with the definitions uh description a
typically chronological listing of
properties or behaviors okay and you can
see the gravitational field of the sun
known as curved space-time is the
centripetal force that causes the
Earth's almost circular orbit okay you
have not explained anything with that
okay you have not explained the cause of
gravity all you said look there's a
field whatever that is because it's not
a physical object okay and you have
curved space-time again not a physical
object and so we do not know what call
what prevents the Earth from flying out
of the solar system
okay what causes it and then at the
bottom you have another example of the
electrons in each of the magnets spin in
the same direction you have a strong
magnetic field that produces attraction
they have not explained the traction all
they say that when a magnet attracts
another it turns out that the electrons
are spinning in the same direction
that's what they're saying but they're
not saying the cause you cannot explain
with the twirling of electrons how a
magnet attracts physically it pulls on
another magnet okay or or even if they
go in opposite directions how they repel
so the problem is that these aren't
these are not explanations but people
think these are explanations and that's
where the confusion arises that's why
this fellow who says oh it's just
semantics no it's not semantics is that
he's just too not smart enough to you
know understand the difference between
an explanation and a description on the
other side you have the explanations the
why okay the causes explanation
revealing the cause revealing the causes
that underlie mechanisms there you see
examples the in centripetal force that
keeps the Earth bound to the sun is
mediated by cables that would be an
explanation we don't care if you believe
in it or not you whether you agree or
like it what we're saying is this is an
explanation by someone a theorist can
come and say look everything's connected
by cables and so now we can explain why
the Earth doesn't fly out of the solar
system the one on the left the blue one
cannot tell tell you that by saying look
it's curb space time because he's
curving a concept you still don't
understand the cause the physical cause
and then at the bottom there bottom
right Angels holding hands between two
magnets and pulling causes attraction
you may not like that theory but that is
an explanation it's an explanation of
how a magnet attracts another because
you can visualize it I can make a movie
of it put angels you know on each side
of the magnet and they pulled on each
other so you have explained a mechanism
whether you like it or not the guy on
the left he said Electra's spinning you
know that's not an explanation he hasn't
explained the cause
yeah he's describing and uh introducing
the explanation the description as an
explanation
okay and yeah for these fellows it's all
semantics it's all word solid you know
it goes in one ear comes out the other
they're not even paying attention
because they don't understand the
difference between an explanation and a
description and so for them yeah it's
just word Wizardry it's just
semantics
okay let's go on with some of the
questions comments people made since
last time here's the first one
persons if a tree falls in fours and no
one is there to see it doesn't make any
sound uh if someone was deaf would sound
exist if sound is our bodies reacting in
the way biologically mechanically How
Sound Works does sound exist
sound is our perception of it it is
mechanical and biological it exists as
more than one person can see this sound
is a biological process or we would just
say motion waves or the motion of air
okay so what is the issue the issue is
that sound is a concept okay so
hopefully sound is not something you can
illustrate okay so we cannot use our
eyes to talk about sound okay the uh
best you can do to illustrate sound you
would be illustrating sound itself but
the mechanism behind it which is uh rare
faction uh and uh compression of
molecules that's all you could do put a
bunch of balls there and say look this
is how they compress and uh rare fact
you know and they go back and forth in
that sound okay that you can see but
sound is produced by the tree when it
falls in the forest whether there's
anybody to hear or not
you know uh there it it's Thursday air
it stirs the it does compression and
rare faction of the molecules around the
tree so sound is produced whether
there's someone to hear it or not that's
irrelevant okay we're talking about
sound meaning the vibration of air okay
so yeah you don't you don't need to hear
it in order to uh
to or be near or anything like that in
order to produce sound sound has nothing
to do with the Observer has to do with
the emitter
here's another fellow he says physical
presence is existing
not all physical presence are objects
well I don't know uh what other objects
he's thinking of ghosts Spirits I don't
know so
he's got to specify which uh physical
presence
um
is not an object okay
again these people put comments
one-liners and they don't put an example
they say for example you know but they
don't do that so I had to put one in
there a ghost I guess I don't know is
that physical presence that an object
okay here's another one it says is is
light a noun or a verb okay is it an
object or a concept aha is it the Rope
or the torque of the Rope an object has
shape yeah
oh by the way we don't have to Define
what shape is
G Can't Define your terms
you switch up your definitions as you go
along
okay the first thing yeah let's address
that second issue yeah we do not Define
shape we do not have to Define shape for
several reasons okay and the first one
is that we're all there's eight billion
people in this conference room
and the doors are locked no one can
leave until we Define the word object we
need to know what an object is
and if we don't Define it as shape we
have to go with the default and the
default is C and touch so all we have to
know is the difference or understand the
difference between shape on the one hand
and C touch on the other that's all we
have to do you know the difference uh
then you do not need to Define shape
okay shape is what kindergartens tell
you what shape is you show a cube you
show a ball and they have the same color
the same everything weight whatever the
only difference is you ask the children
what is the difference between that and
they'll tell you it's the shape okay and
um the other issue is that you know we
don't cater to uh doubles Advocates
extreme doubles after kids they just
want to win a discussion they don't want
to define the word because if they want
to define a word you say okay what is
shape what is uh what is uh the
definition of the word object the word
object is the one that concerns us not
shape and so if they have a different
definition hey put it on then we can
check shape against whatever you propose
okay so please bring your definition of
object before we get into the definition
of shape and then of course when you
define shape they say well what does
this word that you use to define shape
mean and they go on and on and on they
want to go through the whole dictionary
in science we do not Define every word
in the dictionary we only Define those
words that make or break our theories
shape is not one of them so we do not
Define shape like we do not Define and
but or a the uh the Articles the
pronouns a lot of that stuff we don't we
don't
we don't Define every word in physics we
just Define those words that we need to
make our case Okay so yeah we do not
Define shape we don't have to now yes uh
is lighter noun uh or a verb well light
is is a very confusing word because
light includes the Rope so
okay that's the object and the Rope is
twirling turkey okay and so we have two
we have a noun and a verb in the word
light
specific word light okay now uh you can
revert to each one as long as you know
which one you're referring to you're the
presenter you say look I'm going to
mediate light with a rope okay and the
torquing of the Rope is the signal the
disturbance we call light but you need a
rope because you need a physical object
Quantum is no different uh Quantum has
particles okay and so they say look
imagine a bunch of little balls going in
series okay and all these we're going to
call photons and
all this all these photons that's what
we call light so is
light the ball
or is light the movement of the ball the
Striking the target
and it's both it's the ball and the
movement that's what light is
okay and sometimes they put away what is
the way well it's made out of particles
hopefully what is a wave made out of oh
that's true it's made out of vectors and
um meaning
magnitude and Direction so it's made out
of numbers
so that's even worse so yeah first you
gotta determine what you're saying when
you say light okay Some people prefer to
say electromagnetism and it's probably a
better word because we say it's the
electromagnetic rope that's the object
that mediates that mediates light but
light is a dynamic concept because it
involves the object that's moving it's
like saying what's a jumping kangaroo
well kangaroo is the object what it does
is jump and we call that a jumping
kangaroo light is a jumping kangaroo
that's more or less the the context okay
so it's not that we uh just invent
definitions that we go along and avoid
the ones that are inconvenient we just
stick to what we need we don't need the
word shape okay we don't need it for
anything and what we need to know is
that or understand is the difference
between shape and on the one hand and uh
seed touch on the other that's all we
need to do
as long as you understand the difference
we're okay and if you don't like those
two criteria
sets of criteria hey bring on whatever
criteria you have and we'll check it
against shape no problem we'll see if it
says Universal if shape is all objects
have shape there's not a single
exception
but if you have a different definition
we'll find out if your definition your
Criterion the one that you're going to
use to define the word object if that
applies to every object in existence and
there are no exceptions okay that's the
issue that's the task for you
okay here's a father says Chris the big
brain another YouTuber makes a little
more a bit more sense than the than uh
most relativists he thinks gravity is
due to a dimension he explains gravity
on Earth in terms of pressure like the
space around it is enclosed in a box
full of uh Jello I guess uh so put
simply gravity equals Jello in a box
okay I went to this little site and he
talks about dimensions and you know
again Dimension is not something you're
going to use to explain gravity you're
going to use Dimension to describe
gravity at best okay if any if it has
anything to do with gravity which it
doesn't but uh Dimension is not
something that especially the dimension
of um mathematics it cannot be used to
explain it can only be used to describe
more or less like time time cannot
explain anything okay we don't use the
word time or seconds or minutes or
anything to explain any phenomenon in
physics
okay what are you going to explain with
time
that's why time is not a part of physics
it's part of mathematics and they turn
time into a religion you know they
really have some irrational conclusions
because of this word time so it's even
worse than that but no we don't use the
word time in science we have no use for
science for time in science
okay and final one here fellow says Ah
on the other side give me a second here
sometimes they do that to me
okay so Science is based on facts okay
facts cannot be argued away
well uh what is a fact to you is a lie
to me and vice versa what you know for
sure is just a belief you just have
certainty of your belief so uh knowledge
is just uh certain belief or more
certain belief than belief okay that's
how it is and that's what a fact is
there is no such thing as a fact fact is
what uh Mother Nature knows it's already
in the past and some people believe that
fact other people have other facts Okay
so
you know uh
facts have nothing to do with science
okay we don't call them facts what we
use in science especially in physics is
a statement of the facts what we mean by
that is that we're going to State what
our version of our fact of the facts are
in order to give a presentation in order
to give our dissertation
and the other fellow you know he doesn't
like your theory he's got a different
theory he says I have a different set of
facts
okay and if you know uses that as a
foundation for his theory and so he
presents that and he says according to
my facts according to this hypothesis
these uh this base that I on which I
base my theory this is my explanation
for such and such phenomena so no
science is not based on facts Science is
based on explanation only
and please memorize that for next Sunday